Newspapers and television news programs always seem to report about the bad things happening in society.
However, there is a place where readers can find some good news.
That place is the website called "HappyNews".
The man behind "HappyNews" is Byron Reese.
Reese set up "HappyNews" because he thought other news sources were giving people an unbalanced view of the world.
Reese said about "HappyNews",...
..."The news media gives you a distorted view of the world by exaggerating bad news, misery and despair."
"We're trying to balance out the scale."
Not everyone agrees with Reese's view, though.
Many people think that news sources have a responsibility to provide news that is helpful to people.
People need to know about issues or problems in today's society.
Then, people are better able to make informed decisions about things that affect their daily lives.
Reese said that "HappyNews" is not trying to stop people from learning about issues or problems.
"HappyNews" is just trying to provide a balanced picture of today's world.
By the end of its first month online, "HappyNews" had more than 70,000 unique readers.
About 60 percent of those readers were women.
Something else unique makes "HappyNews" different from any of the other news...
...or information websites that are on the Internet.
Unlike many other websites, "HappyNews" gets fan mail from its readers on a daily basis.